okay now some of you are gonna say mr wu
um this is not looking good like we
don't have much time and part three is
worth just as many marks as part two um
but i think you're going to find it's
actually much simpler than what we had
to go out in part two which means that
as we've always said if you are doing
this question or a question like this in
the exam you're like i can't get part
two
because they give you that result you
can use part two for part three even if
you haven't proved it just
invoke part two as i'm about to do okay
so let's have a look at the situation
this is exactly what i was just kind of
flagging earlier in terms of when you
pull the parachute you got jack and jill
jill also jumps out of the airplane and
her situation is exactly the same in
terms of they have the same mass their
parachutes are the same so all your
constant and proportionality in your m
we're going to have the same situation
essentially
but jack is a little nervous i guess or
maybe just wants to take in the scenery
so
jack opens the parachute very early at
one third of vt so in other words they
jack has not had much time to accelerate
out of um his fall right so he pulls his
parachute at that time but jill waits
longer waits until she speeds up and her
terminal velocity for
with the parachute
while she hasn't opened a parachute it
gets to triple of that velocity
jack's speed increases because um
he hasn't reached it yet but jill's
speed decreases to bring herself down to
she's slowing down after she's pulled
the parachute
show that in the time taken for jack
speed to double jill's speed has halved
okay how do we do this
well firstly remember v0 is the jumper's
velocity once the shoot opens okay so
once you have that in mind that's what
it indicates for jack and jill
separately what's going to go on here
i've got a separate v0 for each of them
so first and i literally write this okay
because i need to distinguish in my
working i'm going to have a v 0 for jack
and a v 0 for jill
and i suppose i could call them like i
could add more letters into things and
have them like v 0 g and v 0 j
but that's even more confusing because
like i've already got g it's gravity so
i'm just going to use words to say first
let's consider
jack's situation because we began this
question with him
um when i think about jack's situation
jack's v0 is the one third vt that was
provided in the question right so i will
write jack's v zero equals a third of v
t and you can see me getting that from
this data in the question right there
okay so
so when does his like what is his um
what is his velocity going to be equal
to once it doubles that right because
that's the question it's asking me show
that the time taken for jack's speed to
double right so i'm going to say
since this is his v0 right his speed
doubles um
when he reaches double of that value
right his speed doubles when
v equals
uh instead of one third of vt it'll be
two thirds of vt
okay so i'm trying to find a time for
this so therefore i'm just going to go
back to part 2 and like i said
regardless of whether i've proved it or
not i'm just going to say from part 2
this occurs when
this will be t
equals and i'm going to substitute in
this particular value for v right so it
is a bit of a messy thing because i've
got so many things going on in the log
but it will simplify out a lot so just
stay with it you get vt on 2g at the
front
here comes the log term and then i'm
going to put in two thirds vt um and one
third vt in all the appropriate spots
for well i had to scroll fair way um for
all of this right in fact let me just
copy and paste this so i have it nearby
oopsy daisy
copy this and it'll make the
substitution a bit easier let's let's
tuck it over here and i'll make sure
it's a different color just so i can see
it separately okay here we go
so um to begin with i've got uh the vt
plus v up the top there so that's why
that v i'm substituting for two thirds
v t
and then on the right hand side of the
numerator i've got v t minus v zero but
my v zero is is this v zero right it's a
third v t
there we go okay there's the numerator
there's a whole lot that we can cancel
in a second and factorize out but i will
leave that because you can see the
denominator is going to do the same
thing right on the denominator i've got
v t
minus uh v which i think we just said
was two-thirds
vt and then i've got vt plus v0 which we
already said um is going to be uh v
t
plus um
a third
v t alright there we go
now like i said there's a lot can be
factorized out here right there's a vt
you can factorize from here and a vt you
can factorize from here so you can take
out a vt squared on the numerator but
you can do the identical process on the
denominator so they're just going to
cancel with each other vt squared on vt
squared on the top and bottom so
therefore
let me write that vt on 2g out the front
log off once you've done all that
cancelling what do you end up with well
it looks to me like i've got let's put
some big fat brackets around here
one of these plus two-thirds is
five-thirds
five-thirds
well i'm multiplying on the top this is
one of these minus a third of these so
that's times two-thirds
and then on the denominator what have i
got here um i've got one take away two
thirds so last i checked that was one
third
and then i've got one plus a third so
that's four thirds
okay now again uh close my bracket lots
of cancelling happening right um these
threes will cancel with these threes um
and you can see that
two will cancel with one of the factors
on two on the bottom so that leaves you
with the two there
and looking at the numerator and the
denominator all you end up with is after
you have this vt on 2g out the front log
of this is the simplification 5 over 2.
that's the time what's that equal to no
idea because i actually don't have
numbers for that terminal velocity they
haven't defined gravity for me either
but this is the time it takes for
jack's speed to double so this is when
jack's
speed doubles
now to get to the um final piece of this
all i need to know is well what about
for jill right she's not speeding up
doubling her speed she's slowing down so
her speed is going to halve so again to
separate out these bits of working
because i'm going to have a whole new v0
i'm going to redefine it i'm going to
say well now just consider jill right
this is so
i think fastly superior to
adding even more new pronumerals for us
but i'm just going to rehearse the same
argument that i made before right her v0
is different
it's triple that terminal velocity so
her speed halves when it's half of that
right
so that's her v zero her speed halves
when uh her v is equal to
instead of three it'll be three on two
times the terminal velocity right again
i'm going to invoke part two so i'll say
from part two
and now i'm gonna do the same deal right
i'm just substituting in
here's that result up here in pink which
i will see easy which i used before so
let's just
push it down here
oopsie daisy
all the way so i can actually see it
okay i've just got a different v and a
different 0 which i'm going to
substitute but it's going to work much
the same way and fingers crossed my
arithmetic will mean that i will just
simplify out to the same time okay so t
is going to be equal to i've written
this like 15 times at this point so i
know there's a vt on 2g out the front
log of okay here we go let's do the
substitution
v t
plus um this is 3 on 2
v t there's my current speed and then
i've got
v t minus 3 v t on the numerator because
um that's her that's jill's uh initial
speed once she opens the shoot
that's all divided by uh
v t minus that same three v t i was
saying before and it's going to be v t
uh oopsie daisy that's actually meant to
be my current speed so that should be
three on two i think and then it's gonna
be vt
plus three v t here um there was the
initial velocity now this is the
situation that i mentioned before right
you can see this here is going to become
negative right vt minus 3vt will be -2
vt but this negative up in the numerator
will cancel with this negative down here
in the denominator and that's why i
don't need to worry about those absolute
value signs in this context everything
will come out in the wash
i will do that exact same cancelling of
vt squared on vt squared
there up the top thank you veren i yes
absolutely i would i would do my job i
took it uh i took it back i should say
um you can see there once i cancel that
out what do you get left with up the top
um nice big brackets again five on two
out the front there from adding that
here comes the negative 2
on the right hand side what do i get
here this is going to be one take away
one and a half is negative a half so
there are the negatives cancelling and
then i'm going to multiply by 4
1 plus 3 on the denominator so that's
that
um and you can see all this cancelling
that's happening right it's even more
than before
this is all
negative 2 and this negative 2 on the
top just perfectly cancels with that
leaving you with the 5 on 2 which we got
before so i'll write that just for
completeness so this is the same time
which is when jill's speed half so i'll
write that when jill's speed
halves
and just to tie it all up in a neat bow
um i can just say well these are the
same time right there's a t and there's
a t so i'm going to say therefore
these occur simultaneously
here's my conclusion
as i usually say
as required
so
how's that i told you i'd finish with
time to spare
this this is it um three marks for this
last section here um i would say because
it's so similar how you deal with jack
situation and with jill's if you do it
for one you've pretty much done it for
the other one so i think it really came
across to this reasoning here and being
able to substitute appropriately into
part two and from there it's some fairly
simple it's not even algebra really it's
arithmetic mostly um to deal with all
those fractions and then cancel
appropriately
so thank you for working through that
with me i hope you found that helpful
and this question is far less um scary
than it initially seems at least as it
did for most of the state um and like i
said there were a couple of twists and
turns in this integration which i think
was what gave some of you some trouble
but hopefully this result for the way
i've shown it is helpful to you